Here's everything I eat in a day
as someone that loves to cook but is also 37 weeks pregnant.
I start off with some herbal tea and then take my prenatals.
I hate the taste of water, so I mixed in some apple juice today.
I was also craving some fresh pressed orange juice,
so I made that and then got started on breakfast.
Crepes are so much better than pancakes.
So today
I made a Robus tea crepe
with some vanilla peach puree that I had in the fridge
and topped it with some strawberries.
These flavors together really hit the spot.
I ended up making a banana date milkshake
before moving on to making my lunch.
You guys know I need to have my midday beverage,
so today we did a blueberry vanilla iced tea for lunch.
I wanted something just light and refreshing and super simple,
so I made a crispy rice salad.
I chopped up a bunch of vegetables I had in the fridge,
which was cucumber, carrot,
some purple radishes,
edamame, green onion,
cilantro, and then I had some leftover rice as well
that I crisped up in my pan before adding my sesame miso dressing
and also some chillies.
I gave that a good toss
and then remember that I also cut up some avocado
so I added that on top.
Had some errands to run,
so for dinner I made a slow roasted Mediterranean lamb.
Pop that in my Dutch oven with some Warming spices
and let that go for about three hours.
I wanted something sweet,
so I cut up some mango papaya,
and I made a coconut mousse with some coconut sugar on top.
The lamb was close to being done.
I made my flatbread dough
and let that rest for about 30 minutes while I made my date
Grandma Lauda.
My lamb was tender and falling apart.
I shredded it up
and returned it back to the pot to soak up all the juices
while I fried up all of my flatbreads.
This meal, you guys,
was so good. So I put down my flatbread,
some lamb on top.
My date Grandma Lauda added some fresh parsley and some chili.
Also a sprinkle of sumoc. Wow.
And then I was craving some cereal.